[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but i have to get to seth greenberg the
former college coach espn college
basketball analyst
kind enough to join us on the program
seth good morning thanks for joining us
give me the most surprising
elite eight team it's got to be oregon
state now
it's fun because oregon state's won nine
of their last ten but i mean that's a
team that came in basically sixth place
in the pac-12
that's a team that was picked coming
last pre-season that was a team that
kind of reinvented themselves
along the way and it's a great story
because wayne tinkle the coach
you know he had a son for four years
couldn't get to the ncaa tournament his
son graduates
and all of a sudden now they're in the
tournament uh but i think it's a great
story it's been fun to watch and uh
quite honestly their team is playing
really good basketball not pretty
but winning basketball the team that
didn't advance that surprised you the
most
the team that didn't advance the
surprise most is probably
florida state florida state was a little
bit of a conundrum for me because i look
at florida state and i see a team with
lent i see a team that
you know most times defends didn't
defend yesterday obviously uh
had a lot of different ways to beat you
i just thought their game plan yesterday
was so different than what i expected i
expect them to attack
michael smith on the block posting up
different guys because they have the
versatility to do that
i thought defensively early on you saw
that you could not attack that ball
screen by switching it
michigan was exploiting it creating
matchups all over the floor they never
made a change there
so i you know i was i was disappointed
in florida state maybe
selfishly because i'm a big leonard
hamilton fan and i was hoping to see him
get a chance to play in the final four
because i think he has a special team
how does gonzaga lose
if someone can get timmy in foul trouble
if you get timmy tried you gotta make
timmy defend i think that's really
important certain things you got to do
to beat
gonzaga you got to take care of the ball
you got to take good shots
you got to have a four that can guard
kissbert and you've got to make timmy
defend
you make timmy defend and that's why
michigan's an interesting matchup for
them
and even maybe usc but uh you know
michigan especially because if you make
him defend
and go ahead and which michigan can do
with the way they play offensively
playing through him
you take him out they don't have any
really replacement for him now look
they get a shot up every 14 seconds they
get the ball and kissburn every time he
shoots you
think it's going in suggs i think is the
number one pick in the draft they play
with incredible incredible flow
but i think that's the one way you can
get after them
is my playing for the post and i'm
really interested to see what usc does
with their length and with the zone
their ability to cover the ability to
get some extra shots their quickness
i mean you're talking about team
averages 50 points a game
in the paint and a team in usc that
allows the fewest points and is the best
two-point percentage defensive team in
basketball
that will be just kind of a game within
the game that i think will
be interesting to watch so you think
kisper is the number one overall pick
instead of kate cunningham
and mobley cunningham in the mix there
yeah i
i think i would go i would go cunningham
second i would go mobley third or fourth
here's my concern with mobley and i love
him and i love how hard he plays i love
the type of teammate he is
i love uh do you need to get that phone
call no
no that's well you know that's what
happens to home office i don't have a
fancy studio like you now
i'm just sitting in my office jake the
wonder dog cannot answer the phone
is there anybody that you would stop the
interview
to answer like if bill is called would
you answer no no
i would actually ignore that
what i'm gonna hear about is you know
how the ncaa's messed up
needs to go i keep on telling bills
emmer's so bad
take the job everyone wants you to take
the job i said it would solve two
problems for me
no hey bills is the best he's so much
funny he's so
he's so funny that he doesn't even
realize he's funny sometimes
he's passionate yeah he is and you know
everyone's got a cause and
you know this is this is something
that's important to him but i think usc
uh i i wouldn't take mobley ahead of
kade i think the balls in kate's
cunningham's hand now
the one thing i don't kate cunningham is
not the athlete grant hill is a lot of
people compare him to grant hill
i don't see that now i do see a lot of
jason kidd
and jalen sucks that passing through his
left hand off that ball screen yesterday
was
out of this world i also love his
toughness i love his leadership
i think his game just translates
immediately into the nba where he can be
a winning point guard
we're talking to seth greenberg from the
mothership indiana hires mike woodson
not inspiring and coached in college
i know there's you know the uh legacy
there
being an iu player but
is indiana indiana does indiana know
that indiana is not
indiana anymore no i don't think they
know
they i don't think they know they're not
indiana anymore because they haven't
been indiana basically
you know since coach knight left really
if you look in terms of the consistency
of competing for a national championship
here here's what i think mike what's
more no problem coaching college
basketball coaching
x's and o's putting guys in position to
play their strengths
the key is going to be and look that
matter is a nice move by the university
i don't know that's mike woodson's
higher or the university's higher
because it's the university's higher
it's a bad move mike what's got to have
his own staff now i would sit with mike
woodson in the interview process
and say all right coach we have no
concerns about you coaching but there's
a business of college basketball
you know i don't know if he had kids
that played grassroots basketball but
you better have someone who understands
grassroots basketball you better have uh
someone who understands the transfer
portal
you better have uh someone who
understands just the day-to-day things
you
deal with as a college basketball coach
now juwan howard
his sons were heavily recruited he
understood grassroots basketball
he hired phil martelly to sit on his
bench to kind of help him navigate
not coaching i mean because let's join
harry think about the apprenticeship he
he spent spolstra riley
the coaches he played for that's not
going to be the issue
it's the day-to-day operation and
dealing with the day-to-day static and
minutiae
that goes around being a head coach in
college it's just different from the nba
so i would in the interview process i'd
say
we got a guy to play for night we got a
guy that won championship
we got a guy that we can galvanize a lot
of the people that haven't been here
coaching is not going to be the issue
nba pedigree nba coaching experience
all the things young players are looking
for today
what's your staff going to look like not
you're going to have thad mod and
and coach mod is great but handing him
that guy to
oversee him he's a grown man he's 63
years old he's coached the best players
in the world
do you want a guy over your shoulder
basically or do i want a guy that you
chose
to share this experience with at indiana
so i think he'll hire a former nba or a
current nba player development guy
that wants to get in college you would
think he would hire
coach with college experience uh
probably have someone involved that has
ties to the university but
you know here's the thing you're only as
good as the players recruit
and your players develop and part of
recruiting is evaluation
i think indiana's going to go back to
evaluating players that can play and win
like i thought that like matt painter's
figured it out now here's my question
for everyone what matt painter has done
at purdue is that good enough for
indiana how they perceive themselves now
yes yeah
yeah i think indiana fans think they
should beat the final four i think
indiana fans who know
are similar even though they haven't had
success to kentucky
yeah but seth they see those banners and
then they think that somehow they're
entitled and it doesn't work
you know that this these kids don't go
gosh i would love to play for
indiana because whatever it's that's not
the way it works it's what's the style
who's the coach
who's going in there with me do we have
a chance to win
i and and they might be there for one
year but that's
i i just think that indiana forgot who
they were
and you know i would have stayed with
tom crean
uh if you agree you know but you know
look this is where they are
what about uh texas what's texas going
to do was shaka smart
did he jump before he was pushed yeah i
think he made the wise move
shaka smart to me wasn't as it developed
wasn't a good fit because shocker smart
is a guy that lights up the room shaka
smarts have got to coach this guy's
hearts
chaka smart his dna
and the dna of texas in general just
didn't fit
i think that he i think going back to
milwaukee going back to his home state
going back to coaching
the way he coached his vcu kids going
back to getting those type of kids like
at texas you got to recruit the best
player in texas you got to recruit the
top five guys in the country you got to
recruit certain guys
shocker smart was better when he had
junkyard dogs shaka smart was better
when you know they had played with a
chip on their shoulder i never saw the
texas team
play with the passion and the energy
that his vcu teams played
with so i i would like to see him go
back to his
kind of his roots of what made him
special as a coach now guys that should
take that job
i'm look chris beard's the number one
guy i i i go watch
chris's team's practice i speak to his
team his energy is enthusiasm
but chris beard situation and ownership
in lubbock
might be far greater than the ownership
of people in austin
it's just a difference in the two
communities if i couldn't get chris
beard
i would look at eric musselman
i would look at bruce pearl i got all
that money if nothing i'm getting those
guys raises
but but if i can get him what do you
need at texas you need someone to excite
your fan base you need
someone to create ownership you need
someone that understands the use of
social media you need someone that
understands a playing style that people
are
going to be excited to come watch i
would get the highest
energy winning coach that i can find
that can infuse
a passion and energy into the program
moving forward
when you were coaching what's the best
performance you ever saw
in terms of my team no digital team mess
performance against us
uh the best performer well hansboro
uh probably i wouldn't be talking to you
right now if he didn't rebound a miss
shot on a free throw and knock one in at
the end of the acc tournament
that was kind of personal to personal to
me but the best performance episode was
those
jerry tarkanians unlv teams uh you know
we played them two and three times a
year
that was you know greg anthony and larry
johnson and ackles and anderson hunt and
stacey augment
they dominated the game the speed that
they played with
offensively and defensively they
disrupted you whether it was in their
man where they didn't let you run
offense or the amoeba
uh one of my favorite great stories of
the stupidity of seth greenberg
in a lot of stories of this video seth
greenberg
is my first year as a head coach i
invited the president university
president
uh president mcrae to sit on my bench
for our first unlv game
uh-oh yeah it wasn't a good thing uh we
were down 30 at the half
played three games i gave a great
pre-game speech he was all in and he was
right there with us
down 30 at the half first year head
coach look at the end of the bench
we're down 30. not only did i know we
were losing the game i thought i was
losing my job
but uh i survived that thank goodness
but uh that unlv team
was just different offensively this
gonzaga team
is just different will they be viewed as
one of the great teams of all time if
if they they run the schedule here yeah
they should because so few teams have
been able to do that especially in
recent history and i have people going
to say look they play in the west coast
conference people going to say
they are playing against a different
group of players i mean think about as i
had this conversation with jay will
today
you know j wills do great duke teams all
right we're juniors and seniors
you know we have some good junior and
senior teams but
the best teams in college basketball uh
or a lot of teams of college basketball
are sophomore and freshman driven
the college basketball has gotten
younger now look
villanova one with upperclassmen
obviously north carolina of the year
they won one
more uppercuspin and it looks like
gonzaga or balor
or michigan can win with upperclassmen
yeah you can win with upperclassmen but
the very best dudes the guys that you
know are translating into the nba and
are killing it in the nba
today those guys are all leaving before
their junior years
so they're not playing against the same
level yet i look at this team
offensively
and it's just as a basketball purist
it's beautiful basketball
the flow that they have they don't reset
it it's
modern day basketball it's got a little
european tint to it
in terms of the stylistic but so does
the nba now
it's positionless basketball the ball
moves it doesn't get stuck they don't
reset you don't see a high ball screen
with 10 seconds left on the clock it's
transition
boom the ball's moving there's great
spacing there's random
screens there's random uh on and off the
ball
it's just they're they are different i
do think that
michigan's got a shot at him and i do
think that baylor's got a shot at him i
think those two teams
have the greatest because baylor's got
the best backcourt college basketball
seth uh great to talk to you again and
uh good luck with billis okay
i have no place thank you bud appreciate
it
seth greenberg from the mothership